suit qu'est la rhétorique iem l'arrêt de
secret story
le match du jour c'est gilles contre
maxime vous avez une minute trente
après vous nous direz qui vous a
convaincu et juste après on aura jimmy
candidats sur la dernière saison de koh
lanta il ya hugot clément également qui
va venir nous rejoindre vous vous
n'aimez pas l'arrêt de ses quatre story
maxime galy pourquoi est ce qu'il y
avait un moyen de relancer le programme
en changeant le casting en changeant la
maison en chansons également la
programmation qui est avéré sur
septembre alors qu'il était au départ un
programme estival
la marque est forte elle reste référente
d'ailleurs elle cartonne au portugal et
même l'italie le sais pas si c'est rita
lien à jouer le secret story italien est
leader chaque semaine elle existe depuis
15 ans alors ayons mais il a des infos
kôji sur mes chers maxi mission né en
france sic restaurer avec benjamin
castaldi saison 8 quand ils arrêtent
deux millions et demi sur tf1 avec
christophe beaugrand la saison dernière
quatre cent mille monsieur beaugrand
c'est le fossoyeur ainsi que les projets
quand c'est le fossoyeur de toutes les
émissions en dans laquelle ils
travaillent
j'aime pas ça s'arrête c'est trop simple
de tout mettre sur le dos de beauvent ce
que c'est plus agréable de concept qu'un
problème d'animateurs d'ailleurs secret
story alimente constamment les autres
émissions du type les anges de type la
villa à des coeurs brisés et même
parfois c'est un tremplin pour ceux qui
veulent faire des médias aymeric bonnery
il est animateur sur nrj est bon en
kanaky et chroniqueuse dans ces que de
la télé ou encore ayem
donc oui ça peut apporter des choses ce
programme donc je pense qu'il est encore
de l'aber benoît aussi ira tout seul à
briller mais je vous parle du
téléspectateur le téléspectateur il en
avait marre cette forme de télé réalité
d'enfermement
elle est morte christophe beaugrand l'a
enterré donc en détectant je vous le dis
il y en aura plus vous verrez il a tué
le genre vous faites de l'élitisme
primaire franchement la télévision dans
pas d'enfermement ça existe je pense
qu'elle a vraiment une belle de chances
de survivre d'ici quelques années on est
avec 6,6 et ben on en reparlera de
gravité bas mais je crois que ça y est
c'est la fin j'ai trouvé maxime très
mais très bons rails près de maxime
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous aussi vous êtes moins que
vous vous aimez l'art et on va partir il
est tout à fait il n'a pas été vraiment
maxime les duels pour la changer de
karting merci pour dire deux jours ils
vont venir effectivement j'adore marche
jamais mais même si benjamin cinq autres
beaugrand même si basse synthé sur nt1
ou sur tf6 il aura pas fait 2 millions
non plus il faut dire aussi que c'est
l'émission qui écoutent malgré tout cher
et qui chaque année fait moins
d'audience que d'autres télé réalité qui
coûte beaucoup moins cher comme les
anges que la ville ait des coeurs brisés
et tout ça sont effectivement c'est que
la marque est morte ça ne prend plus ça
n'intéresse où les gosses qui regarde
quand tu marques tu le prends plus c'est
qu'elle est morte lundi soir alors qu'il
vous a convaincu une page en main je
pense que plus + pacsés mais le problème
c'est pas tellement là de l'animateur je
pense que le secret story c'est avant
tout un casting et ce avant tout un
environnement plus les années ont passé
et puis on arrivait budget et moi y
avait d'argent pour faire un programme
et c'est un prof qui coûte très cher
s'est tourné vers moi à mon époque on
entend des 24 24 on attend des 18-24
puis plus puissent s aubin et au final
c'est un truc qui devenu chip vous fait
vraiment je pense le fait qu'on ait
retiré des moyens l'émission qui l'a
rendu qu'il a fait baisser et c'est vrai
que maintenant ça se montrent rapidement
la maison il a change plus que terra
donc honnêtement je pense comme maxime
que c'est un format qui va revenir il
faut laisser reposer mais non il faut
que c'est fini non non non la gare
d'agde était la plus jeune enseignant un
problème d'animateurs ni un problème de
casting c'est un problème de concepts
secretstory a été complètement
ringardisé par toutes les autres télés
récession alors bon c'est vrai but leur
secret mais on en a rien à faire nous on
veut savoir qui m'a fait chaud qui c'est
tout si l'on regarde la télé réalité
pour les histoires d'amour à tout
candidat est aujourd'hui sont dépassés
par les marseillais mais oui c'est juste
une île à émission vers toi là et donc
alors est ce que vous aimez ou est ce
que vous n'aimez pas l'arrêt de secret
story way qui vous a plu dans un cursus
hincapie